The joe rogan experience showing by day
Joe Rogan podcast by nine.
Austin's one of them is a drug addled
shit.
All the other ones in Texas.
We're here about 10 miles outside of
Austin,
Nevada.
I'm with my good friend Dan Dodi.
Hello.
Say Hello.
We just got back from uh,
we allowed to say unsuccessful until it
hits the air.
Yeah,
I think Sylvia and six belt successful
in memories and fun.
We had a wonderful time chasing
unsuspecting undulates with sharp pointy
sticks.
It did not work out.
That means we're bow hunting for deer.
Dan Dodi is a,
hey,
you are a fucking renaissance man,
my friend.
You're a,
an undercover hippie on a hunting show.
You're a man of a great fast,
wide range of experiences and um,
Dan is a work for a mediator for 65
episodes.
This is my 65th episode shooting the
show at.
Dan's been on the podcast before with
Remy Warren back when he and remy were,
I'm releasing that apex predators show,
which is excellent show.
I guess they're not doing it anymore.
Uh,
if you hear noise cause we're driving,
we're on the road right now and uh,
we're,
we're passing through some fucking
strange shit.
We're a about 150 miles or so outside
arena,
I think one 70 outside of Reno,
Nevada.
And um,
we,
we just saw so much strangeness today.
This is lonely country,
man,
lonely country.
I was a lot of,
what do you call it?
Desert,
desert rats,
all these people there,
no offense if you're one of them
listening to this podcast right now,
I'm sure you're wonderful people.
Lots of four wheelers,
lots of side by sides,
lots of long,
weird haircuts,
weird haircuts.
Like they just,
it gets to a certain point all man ago.
Go to cut the end.
They just free.
No is reno is fucking metropolis
compared to this.
And I've always thought of Reno's being
that one of those weird places I really
don't want to go to.
But um,
no offense,
if you're from Reno and you're listening
to this,
if that is is,
it's a bigger state than I thought and
it's,
it's as empty as anything.
You know what the game means?
What does gaming does that mean the,
so yeah,
it's like how much it's amplifying the
sound that's coming.
So if I crank it up way high,
it's probably too hot.
Yeah,
it's making a red.
It's like,
bitch,
what are you doing?
There's a clipping going red,
that means it's too much.
Or I'll leave it right there so jamie
can handle this and Jamie knows how to
do it.
This is a new thing.
I think I picked up,
it's called an apogee microphone cause
some people were complaining about the
sound quality of my ipod or iphone
recorded podcasts and someone from my
message board recommended this is pretty
dope.
I like how it hooks up.
Just hooks it up right to the base of
your iphones.
And um,
this might be the future.
This is really your first time.
Yeah.
This is the first time Dan duty.
You're,
you're the one who's breaking into in
sounds good.
So,
um,
we are about,
we're,
we were about five miles,
or excuse me,
five hours outside of Reno in this
incredibly beautiful,
desolate landscape chasing these deer
that have these ears that they're there.
Fuck,
there's biggest Kim Kardashians ass and
they fucking here everything,
these animals here,
everything.
And Dan and I,
Dan was behind me with the camera and I
was,
uh,
being a clumsy,
sneaky fuck,
trying to sneak up on these things and
it just didn't work out.
But God damn,
it was fun trying to do,
we got clothes,
we got some good stuff.
Yeah.
I got so close that it could have
happened once one time.
It legitimately could have happened the
time we got kind of close a few times.
But one time I got inside of 30 yards
and as I was crawling towards them in
the bushes,
I made too much noise and they'd got up
and bolted.
But,
um,
there's two deer that were in,
ah,
this is too many,
too many details and catch it on the
show.
It's called meet.
Either it's on sportsman channel.
It's an excellent show.
But,
uh,
this,
this fucking trip has been really
interesting.
First of all,
it's nice to be off the grid for seven
days.
I haven't done that in awhile.
God Damn,
that feels good.
When was the last time you did that?
Probably last time I hung with you guys.
Probably Prince of Wales Moon with that
was,
that was not quite a year ago.
Yeah,
it was miserable.
I was less or more miserable than,
Oh,
this is way more fun.
Way Better Mrs just hot.
But I don't mind he,
he doesn't really bug me as long as we
have water.
We had plenty of water.
I mean you just keep your skin covered.
So,
you know,
burst into flames.
Yeah,
I have,
uh,
I've done a lot of these mediators,
but I haven't been doing them lately.
The last year,
and this is the first time I've been off
grid and
I don't know,
a good long time too.
And it felt amazing.
The first three days just felt like a
vacation.
Yeah.
Well it made me realize like we're so
addicted to taking in information,
at least I am.
I shouldn't say wheat.
I'm so addicted to checking the news and
finding out what's going on in the world
and we just,
it's,
it's a lot of times,
doesn't give you a chance to use your
brain and think about what you actually
feel about things.
Like you don't get a chance.
You're just so wrapped up in it.
Paying attention to all the news and all
the information and all the stuff that's
being fed to you constantly through the
media,
through social media networks,
you know,
all the,
just everything.
It's just too much.
I tried to keep my phone off for four
hours at a time during the days,
even if I'm working.
That's nice.
Just try to shut and put it on airplane
mode,
put it away,
and just step away from it as much as I
can.
Well,
my friend Ari got it right.
I can't do what he did,
but what he did was he switched to a
flip phone.
A smart,
yeah.
Well,
sue said,
enough said enough.
I can't do it.
I need it.
I like having the phone.
First of all,
if I had a flip phone,
it wouldn't be recording a podcast right
now cause I need a fucking iphone for
that.
Because the first thing you do in the
morning,
do you wake up,
you check your phone.
Sometimes it shouldn't,
but sometimes I did.
But it is for me using it,
man,
you can't help it.
I try not to.
What I've been trying to do lately,
I checked my phone to make sure nothing
important is going on like a,
I'll look at my text messages,
make sure that they're okay.
Nothing's crazy.
No one,
no nine one one calls or something.
And then uh,
then I just try to start my day.
But I used to,
I used to do it.
I used to hit it hard for like an hour
check the news,
check all the bullshit,
check my twitter feed,
check all the lakes people post me,
check what I'm supposed to be doing,
check this,
check that.
I don't,
I try to do that anymore.
Yeah,
I spent a fair amount of time off the
grid and in this connected like that
through the past 10 years.
It's,
it's a weird kind of addiction because
it's a,
I think that's what I felt so when we
got out here,
it had been a long time since I'd been
offered,
but we got out here and it was like,
Holy Shit,
this is great.
It's good,
it's quiet.
I think we're doing something weird to
ourselves by constantly being connected
to everything and everyone and
everyone's terrified to be disconnected,
terrified to take a week off of just
nothing coming in,
but your own thoughts,
the world,
the actual world that you see in front
of your face,
which is not what we get a lot of times
I haven't,
I've been talking about that a lot is
that there's a real problem with getting
all the bummer news from 7 billion
people all over the world because you
get a distorted perception of what's
going on in the world because you're,
you're connected to everything that's
happening all the time,
24 seven,
anytime,
anytime anything fucked up goes down.
You hear about it instantly and it just
gives you this,
this feeling that the world has fallen
apart.
But meanwhile,
most of the time nothing is happening
where most people are.
It's the pre,
pre iphones or pre these kinds of
phones.
I,
I really did disconnect from,
from news.
I wouldn't watch news.
I didn't have a TV.
I do.
Nick didn't do all that,
but I,
there's no active claim that anymore and
there's no way that,
I don't know how it would extract myself
from that stream of information now
because it's just,
it is everywhere.
I mean you can't,
you can't open one web browser or
anything without seeing anything.
So I,
I dunno,
I have a
hard time with it.
I really do.
I don't,
I don't like to know.
And now I actually,
lately I feel responsible.
Lately I feel more responsible that I do
need to know.
I don't know.
I think it's about managing it,
man.
I think that's the big thing is managing
it.
Don't you know,
you don't have to completely disconnect
yourself from the world,
but just connect sometimes and you know,
and,
and know when you're getting too much.
Like I'll go down those,
you ever go down one of those youtube
rabbit holes?
We watch one video on big foot.
I see.
No,
it's four hours later.
He was like,
what the fuck just happened?
Interviewed,
you've watched several people get eaten
by crocodiles.
And I watched this thing,
the top crocodile attacks of 2016.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Why am I watching this?
There are good ones.
Oh man,
really good ones.
It's awful.
It's just awful to support assholes.
So it's a noisy,
it's noisy life.
It's a busy life.
And to me it's almost,
it's the business that I can second more
than anything else.
It's a constant pushing it to everything
that's going on to the,
whether it's for a hunter,
for whatever reason of getting
disconnected.
That is the part that I,
um,
I dunno it,
that,
that that's what light that lights me up
and makes me happy just to,
just to fucking settle down.
Like don't have things to do always.
And always be going somewhere,
always doing something.
And I try to live a pretty relaxed life
anyway,
but I mean it seems too busy.
Well,
you were taken into a whole nother level
this weekend.
You were talking about one day one and
to go to the mountain by yourself for 40
days.
I would,
I would love to do that.
Yeah,
that would,
I'm sure I will do it.
I do a lot of meditation and then in the
lineage of meditation that I do,
there's a lot of a solo practice are
basically solo retreat where you go
either in a cabin or out of the woods or
whatever you or whatever you want to do
and you just,
you just,
you're just there by yourself doing your
thing.
And I have not had a chance to do that
recently.
I also used to,
when I used to be a wilderness guide and
it would run programs for people,
they would always do a solo at the end
of their wilderness experience to sit
down in the woods all alone by
themselves,
four days,
six days,
whatever it was.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
it's a weird thing.
It's not something I think that most
people are drawn to.
I don't think it's a type of thing that,
that um,
you know,
I think it is a weird thing for people
in our culture,
but I think there's something massively
valuable to be gained by that just self
now and self experience.
Just this reflection.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well reflection but then also
exploration I think,
you know,
have your own thoughts.
Yeah man.
And like what's actually there?
Like what's really inside you?
What,
what,
what really,
you know,
disconnected from all the input of
information and the need to go and do
stuff and the need to say stuff but just
like fucking be
there with what's going on with,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm a big fan of a,
the isolation tank and you and I have
talked about that.
But uh,
one of the things that's weird is when I
tell people about it,
they,
I've had many people says to me,
Oh,
I don't want to be alone with my
thoughts.
Like,
oh no.
Yeah,
you don't want to be alone with your
thoughts.
You want to know how you really feel
about things and explore whether or not
you're right about things are wrong or
whether or not you have a bias or
whether or not you have some sort of
preconceived notion.
You know,
one of the things that I've found that a
lot of people do is they have an opinion
on something and then when confronted
with new evidence,
they do their damnest to try to defend
that original opinion.
Dig again.
Yeah.
They could do it again and they fucked
themselves.
You gotta be able to be flexible with
your,
your ideas or not you.
Yeah,
man.
Totally.
And so,
yeah.
So the idea of like going out to
mountain and being there,
to me it's about,
I think there's a disconnect in our
culture from the actual experience and
however you want to say that.
Your actual physical experience that
you're having in the moment,
the actual emotional experience or the
even even mental experience.
I think that there's so much controlling
us,
you know,
we control ourselves or other things.
All the other forces control us.
But the actual sitting in what's
actually happening is to me the most
compelling,
uh,
part of being alive.
And I think there's a lot of ways that
people go about doing that.
Uh,
but it is challenging and it's not,
it's not something that,
yeah,
you're right.
People,
it scares the shit out.
You know?
Why?
Because it is scary.
I think it's,
it's,
it's intense life.
Some tense,
you know,
so you actually have to confront what
life is when,
when nothing else,
you know,
when,
when you're really just thinking alone
by yourself,
nothing else is occupying thoughts,
not a television show,
not an album.
You're a law.
And those things are great too,
but to be alone with your thoughts.
Totally.
And I actually,
and I think it extends to,
to being with other people too.
Like if I think there is something to be
practicing,
being able to be present in the
experience that's happening.
Right.
And I think that different spiritual
traditions are searching for that thing,
different,
all kinds of different things that
people do to try to feel better and do
better at life.
And,
um,
so yeah,
the practice of doing it yourself I
think is one thing.
And then,
um,
I think an even more challenging thing
is sort of that sort of,
uh,
rodness or,
or,
or simplicity or even connection with
somebody else presidencies even fucking
harder.
So I actually think it opens up with a
way of living life that is a,
I dunno,
fascinating and really exciting.
Yeah.
And an important point about being alone
too,
because when you're around other people,
other people influence your thoughts,
they influence what you feel,
the influenced the way you react to
things and to be alone.
And then on top of that to be alone in
nature.
That's what's,
that's really interesting.
That's really interesting to me because
that was a tornado out there.
Yeah.
It's like a dusty twister dust bin over
the call.
Went to that cross.
God Damn Tornado,
I better run for the hills.
I think that's what hit us like,
you know,
before we came into Austin and we've got
swiped,
but I think it was one of those,
we got hit by this huge Austin,
Nevada,
by the way,
not Austin,
Texas.
I thought you locked doors too.
I do.
I like Austin,
Texas.
I Hate Boston,
Nevada.
I'm just fucking around phones.
Um,
but the place where we are at,
um,
is particularly unusual kind of nature
cause it's,
it's desert,
but it's uh,
it's got these sage plants everywhere.
We should really smell awesome when you
step on them and break them.
They have this cool,
you know,
say he just got a great smell to it.
So you have this,
the sage plants all over the place in
these very small shrubs,
occasional trees,
not that many,
but mostly like these like six foot high
and most shrubs.
And there was a few of those trees like
those cedars and there's a,
and these red Mahogany,
so it's,
it's high desert.
So high elevation desert please.
Big massive basins,
flat basis with,
uh,
pretty,
sharp and tall mountains.
Kind of,
I mean,
each of these basins in the valley and
up to what,
what was it,
12,500 or 13,000 feet?
Yeah,
just above where we were hunting.
We were really high up there.
We were above 9,000 feet and there's a
rock slides everywhere where like the,
the side of the mountains are eroding
and we had to climb up that shit.
It's all these like chunks of rock and
especially problematic when you're
trying to sneak up on these fucking
awesome hearing mule deer.
Cause everything's like clank client.
It's like,
like you're stepping on broken pottery
everywhere.
It's just weird.
It almost looks like somebody made it,
you know,
when you see all the,
it's like somebody decided to make like
a giant runway filled with broken chips
of rock.
Just really,
really cool.
But just like an alien landscape.
I've never been to uh,
the,
the high country,
the desert up there before.
So for me it was a,
it was a first and it was also,
um,
it's,
it's beautiful,
but it's,
you don't want to live there,
it's cool to visit.
You know,
it's like one of those things I don't
want to,
I'll dry it is,
that's my only beef with it.
I think it is beautiful,
but it's,
it just looks like it needs a bath.
But it's interesting too because it's so
perfect for these deer,
the deer everywhere up there and they're
fucking big and fat and healthy and all
they're doing is eating these sage
bushes and then taking naps and running
from mountain lions and shit.
Cause we found some big thick ropes of
shit there were filled with hair that is
either a giant fucking coyote or most
likely a mountain lion or maybe bear.
That one seemed way too big to be
coyote's.
That's a,
that's a,
that was a mount lunch,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
Woke up one more.
Buy a pack of coyotes around us.
Yeah.
How they were fucking scream and they
sounded so awesome.
There was screaming.
It's interesting.
We only saw a deer and uh,
we saw a couple of coyotes or scanning
the horizon.
But the landscape for people is death.
If you lived out there,
you'd be fucked.
First of all,
you never catch one of these deer.
If he had a rifle,
you have a really good chance because
for some reason they know your bow
hunting so they stay and like one 61 70
yards and just fucking stare at you.
But anything you get inside of that
they're like,
fuck this.
I'll be dear.
Did you,
did we get within a hundred yards of
like maybe two groups,
two groups?
The first day we got inside of 30 and I
could have had a shot if it wasn't for
it.
We only had a tag for a buck.
I should probably explain what a tag is.
We're hung on public land.
Do you may not know this because uh,
most people don't,
and I didn't until I started hunting,
but we,
the people of the United States of
America own massive chunks of land is
your land is my land.
It's like that song,
this land is,
you know that.
But it really is that it's not just in
theory,
it's public land and it's rare because
most countries don't have what we have.
We have these giant chunks of forest
that you can hunt in and you could fish
in and you can hike in and you can camp
in.
You can do all these different things,
but to hunting them.
Um,
one thing that people don't know,
especially people that are like down on
hunting,
is it hunting is closely regulated by
wildlife agencies.
That's manned by biologists that are
working on science and data for that
particular area.
So in the area where we were at,
it's not that easy to get a tag.
So Steve Rinella,
how to use his points to get me in there
as well.
And what points are as you put in for a
tag you have to put in every year and it
takes like a few years.
So if you can hunt in this place,
you could probably only hunt here like
every three years.
But there's other places like the Nevada
Strip,
which is on the Utah,
Nevada border.
That is so awesome.
There's some strip that's in Nevada,
I'm sorry,
Arizona Strip,
which is on the border of Arizona and
Utah,
which is the most cherished place for
mule deer.
Where you can only hunt.
They're like once in your life.
Like literally it takes like 20 plus
years to get a tag like area.
I think it's a 13 v.
Yeah.
So it's supposed to be the shit.
So these places,
um,
it's not,
there's not a lot of people there.
Like we were like,
we saw a few people while we were there
that were also hunting.
Uh,
shout out to James Kawasaki.
It gave us some,
uh,
some great tips.
We met a really cool dude from Hawaii,
James Kawasaki.
We found him a hunting up there and he
gave us some good tips about where to go
and study.
Know he's such a fucking good dude.
It's cool when you meet someone like
that is doing the same thing that you're
doing.
And then he was leaving and we were
comments,
be able for generous.
Yeah.
It wasn't a guy who was like,
I'm not going to give you information,
which happens.
Yes.
Yeah.
You get people that want to hoard,
hoard their honey holes.
But he gave us all this information so
it still doesn't help.
That's probably why he gave us the
information.
She's like,
but shit,
he ain't get county thing.
So for us,
trip Nevada folk have been incredibly
generous.
He was doing this and we're uh,
we're right behind a truck pulling a
trailer,
but that belongs to remy Warren and his
family.
And they just hooked us up.
The stuff in the trailer,
two trucks,
it was really incredibly generous.
Maybe that's the thing about Nevada,
maybe it's a big empty placement.
Maybe everybody's really,
I joke around about,
you know,
that place being a drug addled Shill,
but I,
I've met a lot of really nice people
from Nevada.
I mean it's,
it has a bad reputation because vegas is
linked to organized crime and gambling
and all the other sorted shit that comes
with that.
People think of it as like,
you know,
it was horrible sin full place,
but that's just a small area of Nevada.
Most of my friends that I know that live
around Vegas that are involved in like
the MMA business there,
they're fucking the nicest people in the
world.
And they'll tell you like in Nevada is
like what's outside of the Strip.
It's a great town.
Like Henderson Henderson's a great town.
Yeah.
It's really nice place to live.
It's real safe.
So there's a lot of good spots in
Nevada.
But uh,
anyway,
point being we're out here,
um,
in,
uh,
you know,
it just a really fascinating,
interesting landscape to spend seven
days but bring a lot of fucking water,
that's for sure.
I'm impressed that you haven't been in a
landscape like this before.
To me,
this is what the majority of the
American West looks like.
It's Brown.
Yeah.
Flat with know bumpy mountains,
all of them.
Well,
um,
the first place that we hunted in
Montana was a little like this when
we're,
uh,
in the Missouri breaks,
which is a right on the banks of the
Missouri River.
And that's,
that's how I got hooked.
It's Goddamn Steve Rinella.
He was a little crack dealer with this
hunting stuff.
He gave me the first dose for free
and then he got me.
But it's the same sort of feeling in the
Missouri breaks is that feeling of
massiveness and also that you are
completely insignificant.
Invisible.
Yeah.
The universe or the world,
the natural world around you.
It really doesn't give a fuck.
You could fall and smash your head open
on a rock and those wheel dear will
bounce on by you.
Like nothing happened.
You know,
it's uh,
it's just,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing like that.
I think the place it's sunk that in the
most was probably Prince of Wales,
so uninviting
Laska one of the harshest places I've
been,
I don't know.
It's weird though because that,
that one's like heaven.
Hell.
Like the sun comes out,
it's,
you don't want to be anywhere else.
But then most of the year when it is
raining,
because it does need most of the year,
it's,
it's just,
it's fucking miserable.
It rained every fucking day.
We were there all day and Dan Dodi was
warning us before we went,
Damn.
I was like,
fuck that place.
I don't want to go back to that place.
And Steve and I was like,
why you say that?
I love that place,
please.
Awesome.
So I swore twice in my life I would not
go back and I broke that prompt us.
But it is also just amazing.
Just so as far as the,
the,
the animals both under the water and
above the water.
It's just a rich rich environment.
Well then it's,
it's also super unusual too.
Like the way it looks.
It's a rain forest.
It is.
Well it's close.
I don't think it's quite maybe parts of
the island art,
I'd have to look that up,
but he's like,
he's a shit ton now.
Both what it,
when it was really cool about it,
there's a lake at the top that's so high
up that beavers don't go there,
so you can drink right out of the lake.
So we would take our water bottles,
we just dip it in the lake.
It just drink right out of the way.
So this place is almost the exact
opposite of that.
Whereas that place is all just rain and,
and lush greenery and the occasional
sunshine pops through and you're like,
wow,
look at this place.
It's shines like a green emerald.
Yeah,
there you go.
To,
would you rather get dropped off making
keep here and there have to make it
there.
There.
You'd probably make it better.
You wouldn't make it here naked.
Your skin would peel off.
You know,
there you could,
you would be cold as fuck until he
figured out how to start a fire,
how to kill something and where it's
skin.
Yeah.
You'd have to set it up to be a large
thing,
right?
You have to kill a bunch of squirrels to
sew them together,
make a Dick Holster,
because
a lot of shit you can,
but then again,
if you just take it,
that means you don't even have a gun or
a bow and Arrow and that's not good.
Then those things are good,
but I think that Prince of Wales was
like the most profound of all the that
experience.
Like I felt it.
The Missouri breaks that,
that feeling of like complete Ditto,
not detachment,
but like it doesn't give a fuck.
Then the landscape does not give a fuck
it.
It's just completely oblivious to your
presence and it has existed in this form
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years.
Did you get that feeling here too?
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
I was curious because both of those
aunts,
both of Missouri breaks the Alaska one
word.
We're,
we're a non motorized,
you know,
so like is there any breaks?
We dropped the cars off and we voted and
truly,
you know you call that a true wilderness
experience and same thing with Prince of
Wales and we got dropped off by a plane,
Andy,
if we needed to get out there and in a
pitch,
you know,
we get out of there and a picture it
would have been.
So I was wondering if that was a little
bit of the of the feeling you got.
But yeah,
there's a little bit more of an ominous
sitting set of situations.
Yeah.
Here we had a truck that we would drive
to the top of this hill and then for the
top of the hill we walked and fuck did
we walk Dan Dodi and I walked up hills
at Dai thousand foot elevation,
some steep fucking kills two hours and
hours every day.
Dude,
I was hurting.
But it was a great cardio though.
Awesome workout.
So you were telling me about these
wilderness trips that you take people
on,
you like wilderness therapy.
So my,
my first job out of college,
um,
I had been living in Panama with my ex
girlfriend and we were moving to Utah
and I just needed a job and I didn't
know what I was going to do.
And
so I'm going to Craig's list and we
looked at salt,
the area around Salt Lake City and there
was a job advertisement for a wilderness
guide or wilderness instructor.
They called it,
I didn't know this shit existed at that
point.
So yeah,
there's,
there's a huge industry and most of it's
in the western United States,
but their therapeutic wilderness
programs,
which are tied to a bunch of therapeutic
boarding schools.
So in the most basic sense,
there's kids from generally pretty
wealthy families across the country that
are having trouble.
Their parents don't know what to do and
they'll send them away,
you know,
as an intervention.
And usually the intention just to have
these kids go to a boarding school where
there's a therapeutic presence also.
But in order to get into those schools,
those schools require a wilderness
stage.
So,
um,
so I worked for a program and went out
there and,
and just kind of,
it was,
uh,
the type of program where everything was
made by hands.
He got out there,
you will given a half of an elk hide,
you were given a knife,
and then you were taught some of the
basic skills.
So we had to make our own backpacks out
of sticks and elk hide.
We would sew our own moccasins,
we would do all that kind of stuff.
And then all the fire that we made,
we had to make my hand,
you know,
with a boat drill too.
Whoa.
So,
yeah,
so it was,
it was this amazing,
it was really life changing for me
because I you,
I love the outdoors.
I love the wilderness and all that kind
of stuff.
And then I didn't know what I wanted to
do with my life,
but got out to this place where there's
literally walked out into the,
actually,
it looks a lot like this where I work.
So just these massive brown dry
wilderness areas and got out there in
these groups of kids.
Um,
some of these kids would stay in these
programs for 90 to 120 days.
And so literally,
and here's the part that I still very
much don't agree with and I don't like,
is that these programs would literally
kidnap you out of your bed.
There's companies of yelling,
but yeah,
man.
Yeah.
So there's like,
you can do that for a job.
You can be kind of a heavier,
a tough guy that literally goes for an
intervention,
flies to a family's whole,
takes the kid out of their bed and flies
them and drop them in the middle of the
wilderness.
And it's,
it's,
as you can imagine,
it's traumatic man.
It's,
it's not like you're,
how old are these kids?
Usually?
14 to 19 is low.
19.
That's an adult.
Yeah.
Well that's where it gets sketchy as
far.
So that's sketchy.
Maybe I should say 14 to 18 and the
adult too.
Yeah.
So they have ways to sort of override
the age system at,
at times.
Um,
yeah.
So these programs are meant to sort of
give the kid a chance to look at their
lives,
how they've been behaving,
and an opportunity to just kind of like
we were talking about,
but reflect and sort of explore and
learn.
And there's,
there is actually,
there's a lot of good,
there's a lot of good that happened.
It's like it really does help people.
Um,
and there,
in my opinion,
there's a lot of bad too.
I don't think you can ever imagine that
you could literally kidnapped the kid
out of your house and not fuck up the
trust you have with.
Yeah.
It's,
it's messed up.
Um,
yeah,
but that's,
so I did that for,
I started there and then I started
working in a more state run sort of
correctional programs.
So for a long time,
and I lead the trips in Minnesota that
were,
um,
it was a 21 day sentence,
but it was basically an alternative to a
60 day Juvi sentence.
So basically you steal a car,
you could either go,
the judge can either send you to Juvie
for 60 days or send them to me and then
we'd go on a a bad ass,
like,
you know,
200 mile hiking trip or something.
Definitely take that over at Juvi.
Oh yeah.
Well,
but yet big for obvious reasons.
But then the other reasons too is that,
um,
you know,
these programs are generally run by
really like grounded good people that
treat people well,
at least the ones I always worked for.
I worked for programs with really like
exemplary leadership and you know,
I think what these kids could learn and
those programs as opposed to go into
Juvie,
you know,
being in the shit holes that doors are,
it was a,
it was a really bad,
much better option,
you know?
Yeah.
I would imagine that's a way,
way better.
But just to kidnapping part is crazy
because the states,
they've given up on discipline their
kids so much that they just say,
all right,
I can't,
I've,
I fucked up raising this kid.
It's time to just electro shock therapy.
Jolt them with wilderness.
Totally,
totally.
And it's a long,
slow,
uncomfortable shock,
like 120 days in the desert like this
and this.
Oh my God.
So when you get these kids,
so like if they're kidnapped,
how many days into this kidnapping do
you meet them?
Well,
day one.
I mean the data right away.
Yeah.
So a lot of programs have kind of like
a,
an inbetween camps.
So you come in and maybe the first two
weeks,
like a halfway house.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like a wilderness halfway house,
like a base camp,
you know,
like where you learn how to do some of
the skills and maybe you start.
So the other thing is is there's
relationships with and therapists have
these programs and that's how it works,
you know?
So there's the people that work with the
kids directly are like what I did,
which as an instructor,
so it usually there'd be two of us,
two adults with a group of 10 kids and
it was all an all boy usually segregated
into,
into male and female.
So I pretty much just work with dudes
for a long,
long,
long time.
So it's the instructors with lead the
days and you'd usually hike or float or
whatever you do and you know most of the
day and then you would run,
you call them.
Circles are like processing things where
everybody would use will really,
a lot of it was came down to learning
how to communicate and communicating
honestly and openly as really good.
Actually I learned a lot by,
by being there doing it.
But then once a week or twice a week,
a therapist would drop in somehow
magically and have therapy sessions with
everybody.
Huh.
So a therapist,
they didn't even know,
well they developed a relationship with
them,
you know,
and they'd worked with him for,
three to four months that they were
there.
So they became a pretty fluffy,
you know,
usually they became pretty close with
the therapist too.
So did that,
did it stick with many of these kids
have so many questions,
did it stick with them?
Like wait,
how many of them,
like that experience actually changed
their life so that,
yeah.
Good,
good question.
And I don't think anybody has the actual
hard numbers on that.
Maybe some people are looking to get
that and they call that recidivism.
Right?
Like if he ended up back in the morning
are um,
I know for a fact that I stay in contact
with a ton of the kids that I worked
with just cause you know,
we've got to know each other really well
and respect each other and became
friends.
And I know I've seen the benefit
almost across the board.
Like,
like good things learned,
a lot of growing up happened,
you know,
it's kind of like a forced right rite of
passage in a sense.
You know,
the idea that forced,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
Read of passage,
which I don't agree with the forest a
lot of,
I know a bunch of those kids I could
point to 12 right now that I know just
kind of turned around and maybe went to
college or didn't go to college but
ended up having good relationships with
their family,
are feeling good about life.
But then there's probably far,
far,
I know there's far more where that
didn't necessarily happen.
I don't necessarily think it was a bad
deal for them to go through that
experience.
Um,
but it's,
it's not,
it's not a cure all,
but what it does,
I think it's self selects for,
for people who really do kind of want to
figure shit out cause it gives you a
break and time to do that.
But yeah,
no,
I wish I had,
I wish I had more time.
How much resistance did you experience?
Like when these kids were getting
kidnapped and all of a sudden they would
come to you?
Like how many of them were like,
fuck this,
get me home please?
My mom.
Many.
I mean,
yeah,
I don't know.
30 40 50% of just like either shutting
down completely and not compliant with
anything.
I'm more,
you know,
direct,
direct sort of resistance or amy or
things like that.
Most of those come around.
What's up?
Did they come around?
Oh,
totally.
Yeah.
There's not,
there's only a couple folks,
a couple of dudes I ever knew that kept
it up,
you know,
that kind of had the,
had the stamina to keep that up at some
point.
It was,
you know,
it's just sort of like accepting the
fact that you were there,
you know,
I mean cause fuck man,
they get get literally dropped in the
middle of a desert and you're told
you're going to be there for three
months or four months at some point.
You either have to accept it.
Well not either.
I think.
I think you just do just kind of,
you know face reality.
Well for someone who's on a fucked up
path,
it really might be one of the only ways
to correct it,
to give yourself that chance.
Like we were talking about being out
there in the desert,
the high country and you get kind of
like a little bit of a reset.
Like you get to relax and be alone with
your thoughts and just experience a
completely different set of,
of the input of a set of data than
you're used to.
We're used to like certain kinds of data
and the input.
And for a lot of these kids they used to
hanging around with fuck ups and being
around their asshole friends and doing
stupid shit together.
And they get stuck in these patterns.
These grooves get cut deep and the
momentum of their life and their past is
incredibly difficult to escape.
So that's why I was really excited to
hear about this when you were telling me
about it.
I was like,
oh that,
that might work like for some people.
Right.
Well,
so,
and then you asked,
so how many does it work for?
One of the tougher things is that even
if it does work,
so say you yanked out of your home and
uh,
like just said,
so your,
your
home and your friends and your community
has so much to do with,
with how you end up interacting in what
you do.
So even if you get sent away for four
months or even years to these programs
and then you may change,
we pro club,
not even me,
you will change your a kickboard someone
will change,
but then no matter how much you change
it,
you go back to that situation that you
came from the house,
your family,
just the culture that you're in.
God,
is it hard to,
uh,
to,
to walk,
to not slip back into old patterns,
but then also even just to fit in that
site.
So that's,
that's what I've been working with kids
the Way Leon is that,
you know,
go away and have these big experiences
that they,
then they go home and mom and dad are
still exactly how they were.
And you know,
as a try to be impartial.
I don't think I'm good at being
impartial,
but I try looking in getting to know
these kids and all the things that they
went through.
It's so fucking hard not to point.
Every finger had the family and the pen.
And you know,
what's hard is that the parents were
raised by equally fucked up.
So it's almost not even their fault.
No.
The,
the line of blame,
if you want to do that,
can go back and really long.
So the monkeys from the trees,
if you believe in that.
Yeah.
So that's the thing about a wilderness,
like a long intervention like that at
that,
I think that's what I meant about self
select because it's possible for
somebody who really wants to change
stuff,
you know,
to change,
to change the momentum of your family,
to change the momentum of your past.
It takes a lot of energy to do it.
It takes like a lot of dedication,
a lot of letting go of a bunch of stuff.
But it really is a pretty amazing thing
to,
to be a part of.
And that kind of experience does
facilitate that sort of thing if one
wants to.
But then like I said,
once you get home,
it doesn't give you,
it's not like it gets easier.
But yeah,
you certainly can grow a lot and you can
change a lot.
It's almost like we need that for
parents too.
Yeah,
man.
totally.
I agree.
I mean,
parenting is a very bizarre,
it's sort of a,
it's incredibly complicated,
very difficult to do.
And it's an unbelievably,
she neutra responsibility to be in
charge of the,
the really the future of a life and all
the people that life is going to touch.
So if you're using your son is you want
to grow up and all the things that you
teach him and all the experiences that
he has with you will reflect on how he
interacts with other people.
And that ripple effect carries on to
thousands and millions of people
potentially.
It's,
it's incredibly,
it's so much responsibility and it's
incredibly difficult to do correctly.
And there's no fucking,
there's no requirements.
Anybody could do it.
I mean,
it's like one of the most important
things in the world is to raise a person
that's to affect other people in a
positive way and
so fucking hard to do.
So hard to do and yet so easy to be in
that position.
All you have to do is fuck it.
Everybody fucks.
No,
I can't stop thinking about it.
My,
you know,
my boy was born two months ago.
My first kid and um,
I feel all of a sudden saddled with this
responsibility,
not,
it actually just go,
it's going bond beyond him.
I feel like.
Yeah.
I just think I feel so much less of a
narcissist than I ever have that just
that it's not about me and I need to
clean my shit up.
I need to,
you know,
get my act together.
It should give him a as good as an
example if I possibly can.
You know,
I think that,
and I don't know,
you know,
I'm a very new dad.
I don't know this,
but I think one of the best things we
could do as a people,
as a culture is for,
yeah,
Pete,
for parents who are put in that position
with all that responsibility to somehow
look at themselves real hard and take
that time to,
I don't know the best way to put it,
but just improve themselves rather than
trying to figure out how to parent a
certain way or parent better.
I really think the best thing we could
do is just be better people,
would be better humans ourselves.
That's a very good point.
That's very quick point.
Lead by example.
You know,
that was uh,
when I used to teach taekwondo,
one of the,
um,
the things that they would call you,
the term that the Koreans uses sub ohm
Nim and there was one who leads by
example.
That was the,
the idea behind it behind being an
instructor and to be a parent that leads
by example.
I mean,
how,
or sometimes some people learn a lot
from parents being a fuck up.
Totally.
I know a lot of people's parents were
fucking losers and they're just go get
them totally.
They just get shit done.
And they,
their hustle because their parents were
drug addicts or alcoholics or jailbirds
or whatever the fuck it was.
And they just felt the pain of their
family being awful.
Totally.
But that's not a good bet.
Well,
I mean that's third from experience or
learning by example too.
You know,
he can either accept in love with you
what's your parents do or rejected or
you know,
something in the middle.
I don't know.
But so the eye,
that's what I learned.
So I worked with,
with young guys between the ages of 14
and that toward the end of when I did
that work,
I would do more specialty work.
So I do like one on ones to one time I
did a 55 day wilderness trip with one
kid,
just him and I,
that was tire thing.
But what I low was that like 55 days was
one kid.
So he was amazing.
So it was fucking fantastic.
It was amazing.
He loved to work out.
So,
um,
he was,
he was a good kid,
man.
He was like 19 or 20 and just not sure
about college,
not sure what to do.
Uh,
did they kidnap him?
He knew he was coming because he was an
adult.
He's legally an adult.
Right.
Um,
and the first day he showed up and I
remember he said,
you know what,
I'm going to pretend like I'm going to
be here until I die.
He had this really interesting
perspective.
He's like,
I,
he's like,
I know this is going to be long.
It's going to suck.
So I'm just going to sort of,
you know,
just not count days.
I'm not going to like count my time or
whatever.
But he was awesome.
So he was really into lifting weights
and stuff.
And I was at the time and uh,
so we would do pushups one day we did,
I think we height like 14 miles in 1400
pushups or something like that.
Like try to blow shoulders up.
It was so fun.
But when I was going to say is that what
I learned from working with kids so much
is that example thing is there's,
there's nothing to compare to that as
far as what people are,
kids are good guys especially will
respond to,
is that example like you can,
you can tell them,
I mean,
kids,
they catch bullshit the fucking second
it comes out of your mouth.
You know,
if you're saying one thing,
but you're not living in being honest.
If you're not being real about yourself,
it doesn't,
it doesn't work.
So,
I mean,
I think that that was a real,
you know,
and I did this for five or six years and
I've spent probably six,
700 days out doing this.
And I came back from the experience just
seeing this,
this huge gap in our culture about role
models and mentors and just,
just regular relationships that seem
pretty natural and pretty normal.
Um,
that just like I would get into a group
of these kids and you would just,
um,
there'd be something there.
They would recognize something in me and
I'd recognize something in them and it
just a really cool thing to be a part
of,
you know.
Um,
what did you guys do for 55 days in the
woods?
I leave that,
so we would hike a lot most of the day,
right?
We would hike probably eight to 15 week
camping,
backpacking,
backpack up on the shores of Lake
Superior.
So there's a,
it's called the superior hiking trail.
It's a 200 plus mile footpath that goes
into the hills and mountains,
like over lake superior.
So yeah,
man,
we would hike.
We'd swim in the lake.
Um,
at that point in time I had this idea
that I was going to ask my girlfriend to
marry her.
So I was looking for,
there's a,
gets these little jewels,
stones and all the rivers.
So we'd spend a lot of time looking for
stones and I don't know man,
just hey,
you know,
really and push ups and push ups,
push ups.
Wow.
And so a lot of conversations about the
future,
about life,
about yeah.
How to change your path.
Yeah.
Some of that.
Um,
and then a lot of times have a lot of
silence,
man.
You know,
we weren't going to talk what,
16 hours a day,
it just be too much.
But yeah,
he ended up doing great man.
I think,
I think he's off kind of killing it in
life right now.
But that's an extreme,
you know,
that's an extreme example.
So now how is this organized?
So it was,
his parents were like,
hey,
fuck up time to put you in the woods.
Yeah.
Wow.
So they had heard about it and they,
they just felt like that would be a
chance for him to break his pattern.
Sure,
exactly.
It's interesting,
like there's,
there was a generally,
uh,
like different categories of,
of kids who would come to these places.
So there you'd have your,
um,
drug abuser sorta out of control kid.
You'd have your internet addicted,
um,
slightly softer guy,
you know,
that socially awkward.
Sometimes we hit an emotional health
outbreaks.
Um,
they kind of broke,
you know,
into categories tends,
but,
but honestly,
but the thing is,
is the cool thing about spending that
much time with people is that,
you know,
like he doesn't take long to see through
those behaviors to really seem like a
good kid.
And Pretty,
I've worked with hundreds if not
thousands of kids and maybe one,
one,
I can only think of one that I don't
think was like somebody that went and
we'd go have a beer with or hang out
with today.
You know,
like the good kids,
they're really good.
They're great human beings.
I just,
um,
either shitty circumstances are made a
lot of bad decisions or just were
confused or,
I mean whatever,
you know,
I think I could have ended up there easy
if I would've gotten busted in high
school for budgets,
you know,
drinking and partying I,
well,
especially if you were born into the
household that they were born into.
And that's one of the big things
obviously about life is that you can't
pick your parents,
you know,
and you can't pick your neighborhood
that you grew up in.
You can't,
you know,
you don't have a say until you were an
adult.
Yeah.
That's,
we were talking about yesterday,
the,
so after I did the wilderness stuff,
I went and,
um,
I became a high school teacher in the
Bronx.
I was part of the New York City teaching
fellowship programs.
So basically we give you a free master's
if you teach for a couple of years in
high need areas.
So it was an English teacher and it's
really cool to school in the southeast
Bronx for a couple of years.
And,
um,
you know,
just that was the most challenging and
probably rewarding thing that I've ever
done and really,
so a lot of the positions,
so first I worked with mostly wealthy
kids at some of these private pay
wilderness programs event.
I did a lot of stuff for correctional
stuff.
So that was rural poor,
you know,
that was a lot of um,
kids from reservations and just sort of,
no offense but white trash type kids.
And then I moved to the inner city and
worked there.
And so I got a,
I got a good spectrum on,
on working with different kids.
Really just ended up that I kind of
liked them all.
You know,
there's fucking people,
human beings while you were saying,
yeah,
you can't pick where your,
where your front man and you can argue
how big of a difference that makes
giant.
It's almost everything in terms of your
future,
you know,
and so many people don't realize that as
well.
It's a lot of times the really fortunate
ones don't realize it because they just
think that everybody's got it like this
or they just take that,
well,
my life's hard to,
you know,
my life was,
uh,
only challenging.
And then we moved around a lot.
Like my mom,
my Stepdad were really nice.
People got lucky,
you know,
they weren't fuck ups,
they weren't assholes.
They didn't know.
They didn't beat me and torture me is
here.
Such a horrible,
horrible stories of what parents do to
their children.
And you know,
you got to wonder what their parents did
to them that started this whole path.
It's almost like unstopped before some
momentum,
but some of the things you were telling
me about the,
the,
the poor kids that you worked with,
like yeah.
And so one of the kids that just this
amazing light field kid,
um,
you know,
co comes,
how did,
I don't remember how it happened.
I think,
I think he came into school one morning
and uh,
you know,
his dad had,
had bashed his skull in with a,
with a baseball bat.
Just just,
I think he got drunk and got angry.
He just beat the fuck on,
you know,
I remember that morning feeling just so
hopeless and just like,
you know,
nothing I could do to protect this kid.
Like I could be the best teacher,
I can be the best role model and friend
of this guy then than I ever could be.
But every night he has to go back into
this
unimaginable,
horrible place,
you know?
And it's insidious.
There's a lot of weird ways it comes out
to it and it's another student of mine
of mine,
a hug a girl.
Her mom would basically tell her that
she was always sick and there's a name
for this.
There's like a condition.
I remember where a parent needs their
kids to be around so much for their own
wellbeing.
Somehow they turned them into a
hypochondriac.
Yeah,
it'd be heard of this.
No.
Yeah,
there's a name for it.
I can't remember it right now,
but weird shit man.
Just,
just weird stuff.
And,
you know,
I think there's so many people that are
working so hard to do good things for
people in,
in the harder circumstances.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's like an overwhelming force.
It's so hard.
And I,
but here's the thing I've seen in like,
uh,
I seen a bunch of those kids that I
taught and so I taught in a school,
I was their only teachers.
It's of like a kindergarten model for
high school.
Right.
And all the learning was based on
projects they did and they had
internships.
So they didn't go from math to English
to science and all that.
We just worked one on one and they
tried,
you know,
kind of worked out everything at all
times.
And uh,
so,
you know,
they were my students for two entire
years.
And,
um,
the amount of time we spent together was
just really intense.
And Man,
we got very close.
Um,
I'm losing my train of thought.
But yeah,
so there's a lot of people trying to do
good things,
but it is that home life or that
cultural pole trajectory.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the,
I don't know how to combat it.
Well,
one of those,
Pat,
I'm one of those,
um,
programs like the one that you were
involved in.
It might be one of the only ways to do
it.
Yeah.
Or a program like that.
Something that's going to give them
individualized attention and let them
know,
hey,
there might be a light at the end of
this tunnel and it might be a way out of
this.
There's nice people out there like Dan
Dodi that are going to help you out.
And he recognizes that there's people
out there that need help,
but they're filled with that shoe.
And everyday too,
man,
you know,
they're told that by,
by tea.
And you know,
it's,
it is interesting because I'm this,
I was born in North Dakota.
I'm about as white as you could ever be.
And My,
my students who act,
so I mean,
just for facts.
So like the school,
um,
I work at the bronx completely
segregated and it was completely black
and Latino,
uh,
with Mexican and Dominican and Puerto
Rican and black and not a single white
kid in the entire school.
Like it's just not that way.
And so there's immediately this odd
dynamic for me to go and teach in a,
in a location like that,
that there is a racial dynamic present
no matter,
no matter what.
Like my kids would tease me about how
when I was on a time,
you know,
it was great.
I mean we,
we got past any racial barriers or at
least most racial barriers,
you know,
we were able just to see each other as
human beings and him worked together
that way.
But so there is a lot of,
they get what you just said.
They get a lot of people tell him that
all the time,
but there's a light at the end of the
tunnel.
There's,
there's options,
you know,
you can,
you can take ahold of his life,
but just his words.
Two kids.
Yeah,
just lip service,
you know,
and they hear that before.
Like you gotta get good grades or You
got to go to college and get a good job
to hear all these things,
things that don't seem to resonate.
No,
because it's disconnected from the
experience of life.
Right.
So I can go in there and say that,
and I went to college and I had a good
safe childhood and then in a safe place
and I can see that it doesn't fucking
mean anything because they go home and
it's not safe.
It's just not.
And I think that's what it comes down to
more than anything.
It's people are in a state of fight or
flight constantly because it's,
it's really,
it's a safety thing.
It's,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it's like
everyone rinella was talking a those
deer
today.
He was like a,
the deer,
a Jack Rabbit runs in front of the deer
and the deer leaps up.
Like someone hit it with an electric
shock.
Yeah.
Like they're constantly on there,
constantly on guard.
They,
and that happens also with children and
yeah.
You know,
I have talked to him this before.
I had a feral cat and that fucking cat
was wild to the day he died.
I had him when he was a baby.
I got the money.
He's a kid and he was only a couple
months old,
but he was already,
it was already too late.
He was fucking wild.
He was just in his mind,
everything was out to get them.
Yeah.
I mean,
I can't officially say this cause I
haven't studied it officially,
but I think that there are no versions,
if you call it ps Pete,
I'm sorry,
ptsd or just stuck in the state of
hypervigilance,
whatever news.
It's just coming from a place that's not
safe.
A place that's fucked up and to be
expected to,
to be able to overcome that without any
real time assistance and work.
He's really unreasonable.
I think it's just,
it's,
it's really not like,
you can't just decide right to quick
cause it's your body.
It's semantic.
You know?
It's like,
it's either you get to pay to you.
I mean,
maybe it's your mind.
Maybe it's your mind.
Maybe it's both,
but it's,
it's not like you can just say,
okay,
I'm gonna,
I don't want to do this anymore.
It's far more,
it's far more complicated.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a battleship that's moving a
hundred miles an hour and you're
expected to turn on a dime.
It's not going to,
it's just a lot of weight momentum
behind that passed.
I was talking to Michael Irvin once,
I was on a flight with them,
just random and uh,
it was all the way to Australia,
so it's a long ass time.
And he and I were talking about a work
that he's been doing with,
uh,
some young kids come from troubled
houses and troubled backgrounds as well.
And he was telling me that when a child
is in the womb and the mother is
experiencing intense stress from
violence,
from crime,
bad neighborhoods that kind of shed a
domestic abuse,
that kind of thing,
that the child grows up with more of a
propensity for violence like that,
that violence becomes like almost in
their DNA as a response to any perceived
threat,
whether it's real or not.
And that the,
we have to understand that these
children,
like they're being wired for violence,
they're wired to deal with bad
neighborhoods,
bad situations,
crime,
and it's,
it's literally a part of their genetics.
It's in them,
it's their DNA almost.
Or it is so this the republican white
conservative idea that people need to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps,
which is like,
you know the Cliche,
right?
They to get their shit together like
God.
Is it more complicated than that?
It is man.
But so here's the,
here's the interesting thing is I
applied,
do think that I actually agree with that
in a different way.
I think that you can never expect
anybody else to do any of that.
Like the way it is.
You're born and raised in the way you
are and then at some point you fully
have to take responsibility for that.
You know,
no matter how shitty or great in your
childhood was,
no matter what you're dealing with,
I think that that there is no one else
that's going to do it for you.
So you,
I really do think that there's a,
there is a piece of truth in what
they're saying.
I just don't think that um,
that general mindset is nuanced or
understanding enough of what people are
working with that they're unrealistic
about.
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
they might just be like,
well,
what's conveniently aloof?
You know,
they're conveniently ignorant about the
circumstances that are involved in
creating a child that grows up and has
been in juvenile detention since they
were a little kid and has been in and
out of all sorts of police custody and
been in crime situations from the time
they were young to say that you need to
just straighten your act up.
Like they don't have any examples and
the examples that they see on tv might
as well be them watching iron man.
It's,
you know,
it just doesn't seem real.
It's not real.
No.
And that's,
that's an issue I have with that whole
debate or political discussion or
however you want to put it.
Is that it to be,
it's only up there talking about a
situation and never as the actual
conversation being had a conversation
between people who had actually affects
is rarely brought out and it's just a
bunch of people looking at things from
the outside and commenting and talking
about it and not actually digging into
it.
And it's just doesn't really,
it doesn't serve anybody.
I don't feel like it serves anyone.
Yeah.
And it's also like very dismissive.
He was very dismissive of other people's
misfortune and not really appreciating
or understanding your fortune,
you know,
we're all born to come totally different
circumstances for the most part.
And most of us here in America,
we were talking about this yesterday,
that people that are in this country are
so much more fortunate than someone
who's born in some,
you know,
terrible third world situation.
Like we were talking about Liberia.
Yeah.
The reality of Liberia,
which is former,
uh,
prison or not prison,
college slave colony with what they did
was they took American slaves that were
released and they shipped them back to
Africa literally and created this
horrible,
horrible environment through,
you know,
a bunch of different factors,
but several war being a big one of them.
And vice has a really insightful and
amazing piece on,
uh,
Liberia.
I think it's vice guide to travel.
All my God,
it's an awful,
but you know,
you can't say that,
you know,
being born to a blue collar,
white family in Cleveland is anything
remotely as bad as being a child born in
Liberia or he can.
So,
and then looking at that person though,
the,
the child who's born in Cleveland,
you know,
there's,
I'm sure there's a lot of kids that are
born there that wish,
fuck,
you know,
why couldn't I have been born in New
York City?
Or Fuck,
why couldn't I have been,
you know,
it's,
it's just,
again,
it comes back to what you were saying
about being a dad and the responsibility
of being a good person and being a
better person is that making and
developing human beings and creating a
community together with each human
beings is so incredibly difficult and
were handed this responsibility with no
instruction manual.
No,
that's the thing.
No good leadership.
No instructions.
No,
you're right man.
Well
leadership guys like you or some other
folks out there that are doing similar
things that you can find,
you know,
but man,
if you don't find them,
fuck
yeah.
One,
one thing I think it's really important
that you're kind of hitting not there or
we're saying is
there's like a big leap to go from the
place of,
of blaming others and just feeling like
all my shitty,
like look at my book,
what I was eating and it was really
shitty.
It's a big leap to go beyond that and
accept it.
First of all,
no matter what it is,
what you got going on in your life and
then even a bigger leap.
I think to start taking responsibility
for both yourself and other people.
You know,
I think,
yeah,
I think that's what is,
not that it's missing because it's out
there,
but I just think it could be like we got
time in our lives,
you know,
like we're doing okay in general in this
country.
I think we could take more time for each
other in that way.
Just across the board today,
whether that's in our schools or
whatever it is.
I don't know.
I don't have any answers.
You have some answers.
I think you've got some great ideas,
but I think one of the things that we
talked about yesterday was the amount of
children that you had communicated with
you had taught that found themselves in
some horrific situations that you had to
kind of experience with them.
And I think that human beings today,
at some point in time,
we have to realize that we are some sort
of a super organism.
We are all connected.
And if this kid who grows up in this
horrible environment and is just a
abused
and subject to all sorts of violence and
that kids can go perpetuate more of the
same,
if no one steps in,
if no one offers some solid example that
you can do better,
like some,
some sort of just some pathway through
the bullshit and bullshit is not strong
enough worth.
Yeah,
and for me like so I've spent a lot of
time thinking about and reading about
studying sort of both,
both rites of passage at different parts
of the world,
but then also just this really simple
concept of mentoring or mentorship or
role models.
And I think I got real lucky like I had
an eye.
Not only did I have a good family and
good parents,
like amazing parents.
I had,
I have this like string of role models
that I had from little kids.
So we've talked about this briefly
before,
but my first one was my taekwondo
instructor at Russ kid best or Mike,
you know,
like he was just,
I was super shy,
super like very soft as a kid.
And then this dude in a sports car drove
into Drayton,
North Dakota.
And I started taking taekwondo with him
and,
and he was just this,
you know,
bad ass,
brash,
strong,
confident guy.
And then I looked up to him like I,
I attribute a lot of my,
um,
the quality of the good qualities I
value about myself,
both to him and to taekwondo itself.
Cause it,
it teaches them how to get teachers
great things to kids.
And so he was a mentor.
And then in high school I had this,
this farmer and worked on a pig farms
and he was John Weirs and we didn't talk
about shit,
we didn't lie,
he didn't like fill me full of wisdom.
What we did was just worked again the
work side by side and we shoveled pink
shit and dumped it on the field over and
over and over.
And I went to college,
I had this great mentor who sort of,
you know,
nonchalantly took me under his wing and
kind of on and on throw my life,
man.
And I,
I dunno,
I've,
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
it and I really,
I just really wish that for,
for people or want that for people,
you know,
cause cause you can't rely on your
parents.
You have everything you need in this
life.
It's just,
it's too much pressure for,
well also I think,
well as we were talking about earlier,
their parents didn't know what the fuck
they were doing and their parents pass
didn't know what the fuck they're doing.
And for a lot of us that's,
you know,
that's the reality that we find
ourselves being born into.
But I think with doing with some of the
things that you've done and now also
with the amount of data and information
that's available today,
I think we have a chance of affecting
our society and our culture and the way
we communicate with each other and just,
just who we are as a,
as a species.
This,
this crazy,
weird super organism of human beings.
We are,
we're in a better position to change
that.
And then then ever before,
like my grandparents came over from
Italy and Ireland on a fucking boat.
Nobody knew what the hell was going on.
Their parents didn't know shit and they
brought him over here.
They just heard there was a better
chance.
There's a,
there was an opportunity,
I mean they might've saw a photo of what
New York looked like,
you know,
they might have and they took a chance
and they came over here.
That the difference between them and
what the kind of experience and the kind
of access to information that your
children are going to have,
where my children are going to have.
It's fucking profound.
You know?
And I think we're at,
we're a part of something that's really
interesting right now and that the human
race is becoming hyper aware of all the
variables that are fucking it up.
And one of the big ones of course,
is the abuse and mishandling and miss
raising of children.
Yeah,
man.
So yeah,
to that point,
there's this been,
this thing that I've been paying
attention to that I think is happening.
So as we have more information and it,
as things happen faster,
it has all of this compounds and things
go faster,
faster,
faster.
I think that the impact of slowing down
becomes very,
very valuable very,
very quickly.
So,
you know,
we're talking about all these wilderness
experiences.
I also bring up like meditation or any
of these things.
I think that as other things speed up,
I think that those are these things like
have the power to just smack you across
your face and like change six fast.
You know,
I,
and I don't know if this has just been
our observation for 10 years or so,
but I think that,
uh,
you know,
150 years ago or whatever in the western
United States,
if we had slow lives,
I don't think we would've had a huge
impact by going and camping for a week.
But today when you're pulled out of your
crazy digital electronic life and you go
back and we feel that human simplicity
for a little bit of time,
I think the combination of the two
offers a really powerful place.
Really crazy.
Because if you can get that awareness
and sort of that the impact of slowing
down.
Yeah.
Compounded with all of the information
and the power and everything that we
have.
I think it's,
I think so.
I think we're on the verge or a very
ripe place.
I think it's a,
it's a time where,
um,
you know,
people can,
can really change themselves all a lot
quicker or maybe even a lot more than
they think is.
That's another thing I would love for
people just to think or believe that
things could be different,
that they could change.
You know,
because I,
I mean,
that's what I've been involved in for so
long and it's just,
it is possible.
Well,
I think also any kind of a trip,
whether it's a meditative trip or even
just a camping trip or something where
you have that opportunity to sort of
reset and reassess,
it gives you sovereignty,
gives you personal sovereignty instead
of just being just caught up in the
momentum.
A buddy of mine,
my friend,
Ari,
should fear again,
bringing them up again.
It was with another buddy of mine,
big Jay Oakerson and they were,
uh,
they were watching this couple make out
through a window.
They were doing the podcast and uh,
they were on the roof and they were
watching this couple through the window.
It's a couple making out.
And then in the middle of making out,
they started checking their phones.
This is,
this is what's going on today.
I was kind of sad.
It's kind of sad,
but maybe they'd go suck in bed for the
better.
But if,
you know,
it's,
you got to not just have all this access
to data but also have the ability to
decide what you take in and what you
don't take care.
And I think that's,
that's the,
we're passing the wildlife viewing area
cause I went to,
well they think they're talking about
the humans that live here
near in the middle of nowhere.
Yeah.
I think it's kind of super a super
charged time for that man.
And it's cool to see people like
literally change your life.
I,
one other thing,
I'm involved in his,
I,
I started a men's group in Bozeman where
I live in Montana and I've been a part
of men's groups for a while,
a while,
probably six or seven years.
I think it's something that's really not
understood or really not even knowing
about,
but really odd is it's a group of guys
that get together to really practice
being completely real and I'm really
clear all the bullshit out of the way
and it's been incredibly helpful for me,
for me.
Um,
where was I going with that?
Oh yeah.
But just that I've been party are privy
to so many people just sort of like just
changing like,
you know,
being a lot more fucking happy and a lot
more productive and I think it's easy to
get stuck in thinking that things just
are how they are and what sovereignty is
huge.
That's the biggest thing.
Like owning what you feel,
honoring what you want,
owning who you are,
all of that.
Well,
it's also a lot of times people that get
out of high school to going to college
and get out of college and get a job and
get a job and start the career they push
forth and their career and before they
know what they're fucking 40 years old
and they can't stop the momentum of the
life and then not enjoying it.
No,
they're desperate,
dude.
They're quiet.
They're quietly desperate.
Yeah.
It wasn't that Toro.
Most men lead lives of quiet
desperation.
It's such a great fucking quote.
So why aren't we teaching every 17 year
old kid who's coming out of high school
like,
Hey,
that's,
that's probably your future.
You know,
once you get on top of this.
No.
How you teach people like this.
Yeah.
They listen to podcasts to hear people
talk.
They realize that their parents didn't
have a fucking awesome information,
you know,
and look a lot of pants,
they mean the right thing when they tell
them get a good job.
Don't take any chances.
You know,
y'all,
you got a dream,
Huh?
Yeah,
I will.
Uh,
dreams don't pay the bills.
They don't,
they're not doing that because they're
assholes for the most part.
They're doing that because that's been
their experience,
their life.
And they don't want their kid to be a
fucking idiot.
And they don't,
they don't understand.
They don't.
They don't know.
But,
so listen up fuckers,
like,
look around,
look around and notice how many adults
either have shitty lives they don't like
or are like going through massive
amounts of self help or therapy or all
these things at all ages.
And not,
you know,
too.
What are you thinking antidepressants
come from?
Did that many people have broken brains
or is there,
I'm,
I'm not denying that there's most
certainly quite a few people that have
natural chemical imbalances and
pharmaceutical drugs can benefit them.
That's,
that's true.
Absolutely.
No doubt about it.
But I know for a fact there's a lot of
people who get medicated because they
fucking hate their lives.
Instead of picking a life that you enjoy
or working towards developing your life.
And it's something that you would enjoy,
you know?
And one of the,
some of the most satisfying,
uh,
email and twitter,
tweets,
twitters,
tweet messages,
and facebook things that I've ever
gotten is people that have listened to
this podcast and said,
you know what?
I realized I am 36 and I,
I've always wanted to do this and I'm
going to quit my fucking job,
but I'm gonna figure out how to do that.
I'm going to work towards that.
I'm going to save up some money and I'm
gonna fucking whatever it is I'm going
to make pottery.
I'm going to start fucking selling my
paintings.
So whatever the fuck it is,
everybody's got a thing.
And if you don't have a thing,
find the fucking thing.
But you can't think that that whole like
work,
get a good job,
get your benefits and,
and don't,
don't do anything stupid because you
don't want to get fired.
That life is bullshit.
That is bullshit life.
Totally.
If you got a good job that you enjoy,
that's a great life and then your job
doesn't feel like a job.
I mean,
even though it's,
it can be challenging and difficult.
If you could find something you actually
enjoy doing,
your life will be immeasurably better
than if you're just grinding it out
waiting for that five o'clock fucking
Buzzer to come right away.
I like to talk about it though.
I think he's a really important
difference is to be descriptive rather
than prescriptive.
Because if you try to force yourself
into,
if you're trying to be Joe Rogan or if
you're trying to be anybody else out
there,
you want that life like,
like good luck with that in the long
run.
Like I feel like you have to sink into
yourself and just actually fucking be
who you are like that.
It's hard to find though,
right?
It is hard to find who you are.
It totally is.
But that's the,
I think that's your job until you're,
until you are who you are and that's
wrong the way,
don't be embarrassed if you're
pretending to be somebody else.
Cause I think we all get that when
you're trying to find yourself telling.
Me and I most certainly have been
massively influenced by a lot of people
that I respected and,
and,
and listen to them or watch them or saw
their work or whatever it is.
That's okay as long as you eventually
figure out who you are and then it kind
of happened to you before you even know
it.
Like when I was young man,
I always,
I never felt very secure and I always
was like,
God,
I wish I could fucking be someone.
Like all these people that I admire.
Like I wish I could figure out how to be
me instead of wishing I was all these
other people.
And somewhere along the line,
it's just Kinda,
if you pursue what you actually enjoy,
it kind of happens totally.
But it's not,
it's not an easy process and it's a
process of self reflection and you gotta
be honest.
And that's where these moments that
you're talking about,
like meditative moments or moments where
you can go to the mountains and be by
yourself.
Those moments are huge because they give
you this opportunity to maybe examine
your ideas a little more closely instead
of just constantly being,
Eh,
just inundated with other people's
opinions about what you,
you should have your own experiences,
man.
You gotta just,
you just got to live and you got to
experiences.
That's what I think you've got to
experience as much as you can.
Whether that's a trip around the world
are traveling or to a different place or
a hallucinogenic experience it done in a
safe way or whatever it is.
I just feel like you got to,
yeah,
to find yourself.
You'd be,
you gotta.
You gotta test the waters.
He got wires all over them.
And if you're born in this fucking town
that we're driving through,
good luck
handing out cash pay day loans.
Man,
I grew up in a place way smaller and
tidier than this real review.
Dan Dodi is,
he made it through 600 people.
600 how many of them you fuck?
We left.
We left when I was in sixth grade.
So unfortunately these are
probably better off that way.
What's your fuck people they think
getting the,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Jesus.
Kate.
Just leave me alone.
Oh
Shit.
Out of here.
I got super lucky man.
So yeah,
I grew up in a tiny little place.
10 miles from the Canadian border of
North Dakota.
Just like nothing going on.
You know,
maybe this place.
Gasoline Alley.
Speedway casino.
There's a casino in there that's a
casino and a 24 hour gas station.
Fuck,
you can hit it big.
They're,
yeah.
Cash loans on car titles.
That's the fucking title of the
goddamned store.
Cash loans on car titles.
How many people give up their cars here
for alone?
Wow.
Is this fallon?
Um,
it's not,
it's not even say what it is.
Okay.
For bastards,
wherever this is.
Yeah.
This was
Stockman's casino spin.
And when Saturdays come play,
yeah.
A lot of people you read smoking going
on there.
I bought a cigarette smoking.
A lot of people here can describe with a
gun tastes like in your mouth.
It doesn't taste good,
it doesn't taste good,
but it seems like if you know that,
that that's a possibility.
What a strange places.
There's a lot of these places that we
drove through.
Like how about that one?
Wild West town there was established in
1865,
I don't remember the name of it,
but they had the old buildings there
that were there from 1865 that were in
ruins and various state of disarray and
decay surrounded by these,
uh,
more new modern ruins that people were
living in.
Well,
yeah,
the old ones.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they did cause they,
they got something.
There's some class or some weird about
like
mobile homes and like really shitty
aluminum siding and stuff.
You know?
No one's ever going to be pumped to find
that someday.
No.
You mean like a hundred years from now
or 3000 years from now if you find an
old bar,
like that old barn that we were passing
and that little shack or whatever
fucking was it cooled cabin of
distressed wood.
You look at that and you go,
wow,
that's kind of bad ass.
No one's going to like look at some
shitty old aluminum sided fucked up
house.
What you're saying is quality spans
time.
That American flags a little too big for
my liking.
It's at half mast.
Did somebody die while we were in the
woods?
Some shit.
But when a flags at half mast,
that's what it means.
Right?
We missed something.
We probably don't know a lot of fucking
things that went down for seven days.
That's gotta be a good thing.
We know that two Olympic swimmers got
robbed at gunpoint in Brazil.
Way to go.
Do you feel better knowing that?
No,
no,
no.
I feel like,
ah,
I feel better that I was in the woods
and I wasn't in cabin Brazil with a gun
pointed at my head.
Poor bastards.
But no,
there's a lot of,
uh,
we have to look,
we should know that that's possible.
That people can get robbed like a,
when you hear about terrible things in
the world,
the good news or the good fact about
that is now you know those things
without having,
it's not like you live your life in some
sort of a Mormon missionary factory and
then they send you out there to the
awful parts of the world and all of a
sudden,
you know,
you're in some third world country and
you don't realize it's being run by a
brutal dictator.
And what's a dictator like,
you know,
North Korea.
What is it like?
It's good to know that North Korea is
out there and there's some Kim Jong Un
type dudes in the world.
Yes.
When I was little when I was a kid,
but not all the time and definitely not
a gun point.
I got in the wrong cap once and the
border of Ecuador and Peru and got stuck
up,
they call it soft kidnapped,
where uh,
this other dude got the back of the text
and they started driving out in the
jungle.
Oh Shit.
Asking me questions about politics and
my family and all this stuff.
Oh my God,
I didn't really know.
I was just,
I was down there learning Spanish.
I didn't know a global yet.
And um,
I basically said,
listen guys a fucking got nothing.
I have like 40 bucks.
Right.
So they drove me to an ATM and I'm like,
I got,
I got like 80 bucks more out of them are
out and they gave it to him and then ran
like fucking just took off.
Wow.
That was pretty sketchy.
That's the other thing that happened in
Brazil recently presented Jujitsu
student from Australia,
I believe was out there.
He got kidnapped by these cops.
Cops took him to two ATM machines and
made them withdraw money.
Yeah.
Cops,
cops.
Fuck
you want to trust them.
But you know what man?
It's like again,
what the fuck happened to them and what
happened?
What happened to these people that are
robbing these people?
Something bad.
They,
it's not necessarily 100% their fault
that that's who they've become.
I'm not taking away ownership of their
own actions,
but you got to think about the
development of their ideas,
how it happened.
I had this friend of mine on the podcast
recently and he was talking about,
he grew up in a standards Byron bowers
and he grew up in a really poor area of
Georgia and a lot of crime where he was
just a lot of like really fucked up
family environments and he was saying
that when we thought about like robin
something like go into a store and
stealing something,
we didn't think it was a bad thing
because that's how you get it.
That's how you get things.
You've got to go get it,
you got to go steal and that it was
just,
that's what you grew up.
Now he's a successful comedian and he's
doing well and it's like he can step
back and have the hindsight vision of
his current state and like realize like,
oh,
that was why I thought that way.
Yeah.
And I'm sure these guys that robbed you,
I mean they didn't have a fucking pretty
upbringing.
There was nothing,
it's not like they went from a gated
community to robin people in Peru.
No,
it's not like they are doing it because
they were just morally poor people,
you know?
I mean I don't think so.
They were.
Maybe they were,
but what made them that way?
Think about your own little boy.
He's two months old.
I mean you get to shape what that boy
becomes as he becomes a man and someone
did that to the Guy who robbed you in
Peru,
you know?
I mean that is,
that's how it goes.
I mean it really sort of highlights the
bizarre nature of humans raising humans.
We should really be raised by robots.
We should,
yeah,
someone should come along and just make
the perfect human razor.
Now obviously not,
you know,
you're,
I'm sure you're going to do a great job,
but for people who,
whose parents are going to do a shitty
job,
I wonder if they're going to come up
with technology one day and I think they
will,
that will be able to install better
memories and a better pattern of
behavior in a person's brain.
Like almost like they're going to be
able to defrag your hard drive.
Sure.
You mean just like with a click of a
switch,
but he's a little hook you up to him.
Like say if somebody gave you a
computer,
right?
But it has a virus on it.
It's all fucked up.
Every time you check your email and
sends you dick pictures and it takes you
to rush an escort sites like you mother
fuckers,
which you did in my phone.
If the your your computer,
your computer is fucked,
right,
dude.
But if you bring it down to the computer
store,
the guy can go,
oh,
you got a virus.
Here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna,
we're gonna wipe your hard drive clean,
reinstall your operating system,
and then I'll back up your crucial files
and add them later.
Sure.
That's,
that's got to be the future of human
beings.
I think you're totally right.
But I think that there's some things
that are acting in that way already.
There's participate in your child's
life,
even if it's uncomfortable suit,
man,
what the fuck?
Massive.
No,
they're sharing the message.
I know,
but what is that?
If it's uncomfortable,
even if it's an that's a billboard here,
the middle of nowhere participating in
your child's life,
even if it's uncomfortable.
Who though?
Fuck sees that billboard and goes,
you know what?
I'm going to stop ignoring my kids doing
math.
I'm going to participate even if it's
uncomfortable because I need my math.
Well,
fuck man.
If that sign makes it happen for one
fucking kid.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
I would,
I was saying there's a lot of recent
research and study that that has
happened,
specifically
ptsd and in,
in that realm
that shows how memories and our
experiences when we're young and older,
how they truly are stored in our body
and that there are techniques available
now that truly can unlock and free
those.
And it's,
it's,
it's not psychology in the sense of just
talk therapy or just figuring things out
or analyzing.
I think it's,
it's,
it's much more a body body based.
So the idea is that if there is an
experience that happens,
the natural human ranges too,
if it's overwhelming,
right?
You fight,
you run or flight or you freeze.
And it's the freezing that these people
will argue that things literally get
like locked and etched into your bodies,
either yourselves or your musculature.
Well,
I dunno what,
wherever it is,
but that through processes of awareness
and relaxation and,
and being able to go into that,
you really can open and release a lot of
that.
So it's not an automatic hit a button
defrag the entire thing.
But there are things that people do
that,
that truly work in that way and in that
direction.
And it's not mainstream at all.
You know,
I think it will be one day and actually
really think it will be.
Um,
but I think that there's proof now that
things are more malleable,
our memories are more malleable,
are sort of set patterns,
although they're very firm can be
shifted.
And I think there's a lot of hope in
that.
I think it's really cool.
I,
I don't,
I don't feel like that's an accepted
viewpoint at this point.
Well,
I think it's being more and more
accepted.
I think people are understanding now
more and more that there's a method that
the human mind has sort of undergone in
order to take these memories in the
first place.
And if there's a way to reexamine those
initial ideas and form new ideas based
on better data and a better
understanding of how your actual,
your mind works.
Very few people know how their mind
works.
They just know that I get mad when this
happens.
Sure.
This pisses me off.
And you know what,
one thing that's uh,
a beautiful idea that has been going
around is look at something when it
happens and decide how to make that a
positive for you and decide how to give
that thing meaning because nothing truly
has any meaning other than the meaning
that you give it.
And the meaning that I might have to
something might be very different than
you would have for the exact same
experience.
And we don't even know who's right or
wrong until you look at like where that
path takes you.
And I might look at it,
go,
you know what 10 toady was right.
I should just let that brush off my
shoulders.
Look,
he did and now he's doing great.
Me.
I'm still carrying around that one
fucked up experience.
Yeah.
I mean there's people that are still
repeating arguments that they had in the
ninth grade while they're in their car.
They're sitting there going,
this motherfucker thinks you can get
away with that off to cause us.
Oh,
go fucking foreign number.
I know for sure tomorrow,
girl.
Ooh,
yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of,
a lot of stuff that we carry around in
our brains and we don't know why it's
even there.
It's just bouncing around and he got to
do a cleanup,
uh,
de Frag.
Yeah.
Well I think one of the best tools to
begin that entire process is simple
mindfulness practices,
which are,
so what that means is that when
something fucked up happens and you're
going to immediately have that knee jerk
reaction,
all it is is that you,
you have,
you keep it a little fucking space and
you let it be there and then you can
decide to freak out or do whatever you
want.
Give it a lot of space.
Give it a lot of space and think about
it.
Don't,
don't let the momentum of every event
run your life because you'll just be
bouncing from one catastrophe to the
next and mindfulness is like a term that
gets really bandied about a lot lately,
but I think the way you're describing it
as she is very important like under
examine these things.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
It,
well,
it's an overused terminance and a
misunderstood term,
but I think in,
it's a very simple,
practical way.
It's just being able to just being aware
of what's happening,
you know,
and being in the moment,
being in the moment.
Don't live in the past.
Thinking about the argument that you got
in the ninth grade.
Don't think about your future.
Only think about this moment right now
because this is what you have.
Look,
you and I are in this car driving down
this godforsaken shit hole highway.
We could get hit in the head with a
fucking media before this podcast even
makes it to the Internet.
We don't know.
We're assuming right now as we speak in
the dimension of this is going to get
out,
but it might not.
It might not.
I like what you said about you know,
taking things as learning opportunities,
you know in general that that just
anything in life that happens to you,
whether it's good or bad is an
opportunity you can capitalize them.
Just cause you can learn from it.
You know
you can,
it's just,
it's hard to break free of the parents
and you used to have,
that's where I really advocate self help
books,
you know?
Even though like a lot of people think
self help books are bullshit.
You know why their bullshit because most
people don't really listen.
They don't really know.
They don't do anything to try to change
the pattern of behavior that they're
stuck in.
They just read the book and you go,
oh well they don't do anything.
You've got to do something about it.
But being inspired,
you know,
even sometimes a fucking really good
movie can change your life because it,
it'll make a little incremental change
in a certain direction.
And then over time,
that could be a gigantic factor in
determining your happiness or your
unhappiness depending on like how you
choose to behave and think.
Yeah,
I think there's a big stigma to against
self help.
And then I think for guys especially,
but probably for everybody that we just
got to get over that shit,
you know,
it's got gotta be okay and I don't know
because all of that self help spiritual
type stuff that's,
you know,
made fun of and made fun of for good
reasons.
But,
but there's some,
there's some things in there that,
that aren't all that right.
There's been just incredibly health
Yonis patellas calling us,
don't get no fuck you hang up on him.
How's it going to,
I was going to talk to him and say
something silly,
but we're,
when a podcast,
Yani,
I hope you understand 60 miles outside
of Reno,
wherever the fuck we are.
We're headed to the metropolis of Reno,
Nevada.
Andrew dice clay was here the day before
we left,
but the show day we're leaving.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
I was going to call them and say hi,
stop on it.
But we had to drive five hours to the
middle of nowhere.
Um,
so let's wrap this thing up was bring it
on back home.
But I think your life experiences and
what you're trying to do is very
knowable dude.
And I think what you're trying to do and
what you have done is very exceptional.
And that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to do this with you because this
story is that you were telling me over
this past weekend,
the all the other times we've hung out
together over the past few years since I
met you in 2012.
Is that a copy hit the brakes with the
cops,
the fuzz baby instead of cop?
Nope.
It looks like,
um,
those stories are there.
Powerful man.
And I think,
uh,
it's,
it's nice for people to know there's
people like you out there.
Thanks man.
I appreciate that.
So anything else you'd like to say to
the world?
Cause it's not,
I used to say America than people in
Europe got mad at me.
I don't think so.
No,
that's it.
And Dan dougherty has spoken.
You fucks.
So Dan is most likely going to start his
own podcast someday.
And I know people like,
God damn it,
Rogan,
you're always trying to get people to
start podcasts.
It's not even my idea.
You fucking assholes.
It's dead until these idea.
He wants to do a podcast.
And I think if you did want it would be
awesome.
So hopefully,
uh,
you will do that and I'll have you on
again when you're launching that and
we'll let everybody know about that.
Thanks man.
Appreciate it.
All right,
my brother,
thank you so much and thank you
everybody for listening and,
uh,
that's it.
We're done.
See Ya.
Bye.
Wow.